you keep saying in every interview the
only man I ever really love was Tommy
Lee I had two beautiful boys with him so
and it was really a heightened kind of
romantic beginning and that's every
girl's fantasies to be worshiped like
that and we worship each other and um
had two beautiful boys so and he's a
worship him or is it is it real Love Is
it real romantic love and have you ever
experienced real romantic love well
romantic love isn't I always felt like
romantic love might not be sustainable
so if you want to have that kind of
love affair it's just gonna have a
season you know it's not going to last
forever but that's only my experience I
mean I'm sure there's people out there
that have these loving relationships
forever but
um
and I don't think I ever gave myself a
chance to have another relationship
after that that was
of any value you know it was more like
trying to put a family unit back
together but I wasn't really in love I
just was going through the motions and
then realizing I have nothing in common
with this person like there's just
nothing like I had with Tommy and
nothing
that's
you know it's just more stuff like more
more stuff to kind of bring me down like
I was putting people in my life to
um
kind of numb some of the pain or be with
someone companionship but
nothing
nothing healthy
yeah would you like like some of the
marriages were quick as he pointed out
you know like I don't know how long you
were married a Kid Rock but what is it
like after you get like when do you know
oh my God this was a tremendous [__]
mistake do you know right away or did
you did you did
right when I got married you knew it was
a mistake when the when the ceremony was
going on in other words
well just after
time how does that work Pam explain it
well I know it's embarrassing it's just
the flaw is it embarrassing I don't know
I mean it's like I just feel like I just
jump into something because you know
Tommy and I did and it was we had this
you know incredible connection
but then you jump into something and
it's like oh it's not this incredible
connection it's this just do something
else
do you make yourself unavailable you
don't want to be me but I think I detach
a little bit and I think that's what's
kind of made people a little crazy and
any sign of you know violence or a kind
of a disrespect or lying is my excuse to
leave you know and I and that's it's
always kind of comes down to that like
someone's breaking things or Screaming
or something like that I just I can't
take that kind of
get out of it run for the Hills right
this last year I've been alone and it's
been in a really incredible year
for me you know just kind of going
through
looking back and reflecting on
everything and
um you know so it's it's been good I
mean like you have to be able to be
alone too before you can be with
somebody else so I feel like I'm just
kind of growing up right now it's taken
a long time